I'm here to remind you that tomorrow's
voting day and I'm here to say I count
on your support the u.s. presidential
election takes place every four years if
you want to make it into the White House
it's a long and tough fight I will fight
for you and I will win for you
battling your opponents in front of the
nation putting everything on the line to
become leader of the free world before
you can even think about running you
have to meet three basic criteria these
were written into the Constitution by
America's founding fathers you have to
be 35 years or older born in the US and
you have to have lived here for at least
fourteen years so it sounds like there's
a lot of people who could be President
but there's one crucial thing any
candidate needs money and lots of it
but he is spending hundreds and hundreds
of millions of dollars to buy the
election so how expensive is running for
president the 2016 election cost a
massive 2.4 billion dollars most of this
money came from rich donors usually the
Republican and Democrat nominee spend
roughly the same amount in a fight for
the White House
however Donald Trump beat his rival
Hillary Clinton by spending only half as
much as her his domination of the news
cycle whether good or bad coverage gave
him a huge and breathe boost they're
bringing drugs they're bringing crime
they're rapists I like him so much he
say he's so charismatic and he's not
politically correct build that wall
build that wall build that wall but
where does all this money go on the
campaign trail a lot goes on advertising
an airtime is expensive
then there's the staff who strategize
and the consultants who carry out
polling and lots of traveling to rallies
and events all over the country to
provide that leadership is our challenge
in 1992 and that is why today I proudly
announce
candidacy for president of the United
States so money is really important but
name recognition also helps Americans
have elected an actor and the TV star to
the White House we had tremendous
success in The Apprentice and the
presidency has attracted members of
several political dynasties if you're
not an a-lister a background in politics
helps presidential contenders often come
from the House of Representatives or the
Senate US presidents can only serve two
terms so depending on how long the
current president has been in office one
or both major parties will be selecting
a new nominee before an election the
Republicans and Democrats decide their
nominee by holding a series of primaries
and caucuses these votes are held in
counties across each state and staggered
throughout an election year in a primary
voters cast a ballot in secret but a
caucus is a much more public and often
raucous affair Iowa and New Hampshire
are the first States to decide New
Hampshire has long been known as a bump
in the road for frontrunner candidates
who do well in these early races get a
huge boost to their campaign but the
nomination isn't one that easily and you
have to listen to the voters for some
it's all about picking the right moment
to drop out and endorse the front-runner
now some 300 delegates behind Vice
President Biden and the path toward
victory is virtually impossible
eventually a party selects a nominee and
their bid for the White House comes down
to getting the mats right when Americans
heads the polls they're not actually
voting for a candidate technically
they're voting for electors who are
aligned with a party this system is
known as the Electoral College each
state has a certain number of electoral
college votes based on population to
become president you need to win 270
votes
you can predict the way some states are
likely to vote for instance Texas
usually backs a Republican what
California tends to go with a Democrat
so the election really comes down to a
few key swing states like Michigan and
Florida it's entirely possible that
someone could win more votes than any
other candidate at the ballot box but
lose the electoral college and therefore
lose the election which is exactly what
happened to Hillary Clinton this is not
the outcome we wanted or we work so hard
for and I'm sorry that we did not win
this election so how to candidates
capture public imagination a memorable
catchphrase helps we are going and you
need to perform well under pressure
that's in fit you know WikiLeaks just
actually came out John Podesta said some
horrible things about you and boy was he
right and it's good to have stamina you
already are the oldest president in
history and some of your staff say you
were tired after your most recent
encounter with mr. mr. Mondale this is
there any doubt in your mind that you
would be able to function in such
circumstances not at all I will not make
age an issue of this campaign I am NOT
going to exploit for political purposes
my opponents youth and inexperience
America's president gets to rule the
world's most powerful country you can
start and end wars and determine the
direction of the global economy the
campaign may seem like an endurance test
but it's just the beginning for whoever
wins
tonight more than 200 years after a
former colony won the right to determine
its own destiny
the task of perfecting our union moves
forward the hard work really starts when
you enter the White House thank you
god bless america
[Applause]
you